you may not realize it but from the
moment you got out of bed today to the
point where you sat down to watch this
video you've essentially been swimming
why because air is a fluid just like
water it has waves and Eddie's it flows
and when you push air out of the way it
rushes around you into a wake so why
don't we notice it most of the time we
commonly think of air as empty space but
while one cubic centimeter of
interstellar space the volume and the
tip of your pinky finger contains
roughly one atom the same volume of air
has about 10 quintillion molecules if
that sounds hard to wrap your head
around it happens to be about the same
as the number of insects alive on the
planet all crawling climbing and flying
over each other in an enormous tightly
packed swarm when this swarm of
molecules runs into things it exerts a
force pressing against the boundaries of
the fluid like water pressing against
the glass of a bottle this is known as
air pressure and while air is lighter
than water all those molecules still get
pretty heavy with the total air filling
a typical school gym weighing about as
much as an adult elephant so when you
walk into a gym how come you're not
immediately crushed by the elephant of
air in the room well first of all
because most of it is pressing on the
floor and the walls and the part that is
pressing on you is pushed back by the
pressure inside you you see the air as
well as the water and everything else
that fills our bodies exerts an amount
of pressure equal to that of the air
outside of course this is no accident
it's precisely what allows us to survive
in the normal atmosphere and what makes
it more difficult at high altitudes or
deep water and we normally don't feel
the air pressing on us because it's
generally uniform so even though
different amounts of air molecules are
hitting you at different times the swarm
is so thick that all those little
differences average out what happens
when air pressure isn't uniform this
means that the molecules are pushing
harder in one region of air than another
driving the airflow from the higher
pressure region to the lower we feel
this flow directly as
and the pressure systems that
meteorologists are always going on about
are responsible for other weather
changes from the mundane to the
catastrophic but differences in air
pressure do more than just let us
complain about the weather they're the
very reason we're alive we breathe by
lowering the pressure in our lungs
allowing air to rush in so the next time
you take a deep breath
think of the unfathomable number of air
molecules you're commanding to move we
look up at the night sky to ponder the
infinity of space but unless you're
watching this video from that deep space
there are more air molecules in and
around your body than there are grains
of sand in all the world's beaches and
deserts stars in the visible universe or
both of those numbers combined the
vastness of the universe is right in
front of you and inside you
you